[Music]
foreign
this is the greatest ride on Earth yeah
Mariska Hargitay is all in with the
spirit of giving this year gifting fans
with a rare glimpse of her and husband
Peter Herman's little ones
you know with three kids and with busy
lives it's so much about like trying to
survive Mission slips and sneakers the
couple's parents to three kids Sons
August and Andrew and daughter Amaya
we're a team and they're loving and kind
and you know we treat each other with
love and what better way to show love
around the holidays than a trip to
Disney World you know it was so much fun
yeah fun and a little bit of magic are
all over the picks Mariska shared to
Instagram like her photo op with the
mouse and charge himself Mickey and in
another snap Mariska cradles one of her
kiddos during the fireworks finale
other people we're leaving
[Music]
she even takes fans over to Epcot where
Guardians of the Galaxy Cosmic rewind
might be the family favorite
on the greatest ride on Earth and I just
want to let everybody know that and
Mariska doubles down to the caption best
ride ever Julianne Hough even chimed in
telling Mariska she's obsessed with this
ride Guardians of the Galaxy is
America sticks with a Disney theme on
the grid also sharing a throwback of mom
and dad at Disneyland with little Andrew
complete with a photobomb from Midway
mania's Mr Potato Head hey Ham look I'm
Picasso as fans know Mariska and Peter
prefer to keep their kids off the gram
making these moments all the more
special
but flashback to 2013 the whole fam
stepped out to celebrate marishka's star
on the Walk of Fame and to August
I know that one day you will grow into
an understanding of how brightly
the three of you shine and to me and
daddy's life and to Peter
you're too good to be true whether it's
a relationship that exists you know in
the public eye to some degree or it
doesn't I think that you know our son
our son plays basketball and and his
coach says fundamentals fundamentals
fundamentals right and so I think that
when it comes to relationships and I
don't and I don't even say this as
advice because I because we're not
I think that it's it's um it's
fundamentals yep whether Hollywood
Boulevard or Main Street USA this power
couple knows how to make it work Peter
knows that I'm always right and I know
the answer is always right so
[Music]